hey everyone how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel so
today's video is a stationary haul video
i've done a couple of these in the past
and recently i was sent a huge box
of stationery supplies from my uncle
and i thought i would talk about them
the ones that i like the ones that i'm
excited by
i thought we could use this time to also
just kind of catch up a little bit
because
a lot of my recent videos well i'm so
proud of them
uh they've been very like well
researched they have a script and
everything
and it's been a while since i literally
just like sat down in front of a camera
and just like had kind of a
heart-to-heart stream of consciousness
video
i enjoy making these ones because i
don't know what's gonna
happen i don't even have an outline for
this thing except i'm gonna pick things
out of here and show them to you
so hope you enjoy also the view of my
short hair
actually there's been other videos with
my short hair before but now you can see
it in all of its glory
okay so let's talk about what's in here
there's some really cool things that
like i've got this package like a while
ago for my uncle
and i've already been using quite a few
of these things but there's also things
that
uh i'm like you know when you like get
new stuff
and like you don't want to use it
because if you use it then it'll be used
and you kind of want it to stay in this
like
pristine condition forever that's me i
think that's kind of like a hoarder
mentality a little bit
i buy things and i never use them or
like i buy clothes and i don't wear them
for like two weeks because i'm like oh
but it's perfect
right now so some of these are like that
other ones are not
those of you who watching my videos for
a while know that i like a mix of
digital and analog products
maybe it's just like the japanese person
in me that can't let go of just like
paper things
but even though like i was developing
ios apps and i was like
super techy software engineer for a
while
i feel like they're just it's just not
the same you know as using like actual
physical tangible things so i'm really
excited for
a lot of these items because they help
me just kind of like stay more in touch
with just like my physical surroundings
i guess okay one of the first things
that i want to talk about are these
planners
okay so i'll be real i haven't used them
because
i'm terrible at keeping paper planners
but i'm really happy to own them
because of the thought that i could use
them these are supposed to be kind of
like a diary life and idea one so you
can put like
your own diary as well as like put use
it as like a calendar and then also put
ideas in them
and you can take them out of the thing
if you want to
so yeah i don't know also also
i don't know about you all but like i
love the feeling of
paper from asia these like all of the
stationaries from china
the chinese japanese korean stationery
the paper quality
is just different and i just i love it
like it's very smooth
it feels nice like i feel like asian
stationery products really think about
the
overall user experience of stationery
and using it
but anyway how are you all doing how's
covid where you are
what's on your mind what are you
struggling with i'm curious to know
as for me what have i been thinking
about and struggling with
i've just been thinking a lot about how
to have a more balanced life
recently i've just been taking a lot of
like breaks and stuff
um i think i'm finally like falling into
and being used to the whole fact that i
work for myself
so if i want to take an hour long walk
in the afternoon i can but so can you
too because
we're all working remotely and whatnot
but i think i just feel more like i'm in
charge of my own life these days
and that's nice but it's also just been
a weird time because it's like where
we've been in lockdown for like a year
and a half and a lot of
parts of the world still are and covet
is still very much real and so
like it's like oh we're adjusting to the
new normal actually
no not quite yet but like it is more
normal than it was before
but not entirely so we just have to be
cautious and careful
and like check your privilege and be
thankful for what we do have so
it's just a weird time speaking of
lockdown actually so
y'all might be familiar with campus
notebooks campus notebooks i feel like
are like so common so popular if you're
asian you've probably had them before
i love campus notebooks like i bought
them and used them
in college in high school specifically
mostly because american notebooks are so
bulky and they like weigh so much to
carry around
versus these are nice and slim um but
like the pages are still
like you can still fit as much
information in them they're all kind of
like travel themed and i say it's
related to covid because cochlear who's
the company that makes campus notebooks
they're like we've been in lockdown for
a year no one's traveled what if we kind
of like
give the sense that we traveled by
creating notebooks that like
are kind of these cute designs i think
these are like really like russian
themed
so i think that's just a fun way i feel
like that's a very like
nice way to like allow yourself to feel
different
about your surroundings but not actually
have to go anywhere and put yourself in
danger
i also have a mini pack too so no
shortage of notebooks here
oh also if you're interested in buying
any of these products
they only really sell them in china so
you can buy them through alibaba
i'm not like sponsored i was just gifted
a lot of these but i'll leave links in
the description box down below in case
you are interested in them it's been
uh like a year and a half since i like
went full time on youtube and so that's
been kind of like a reflection point for
me
um it's been cool to just like see how
hello mayuko and my youtube channel has
grown and transformed and how my content
has changed
uh i feel like i'm i'm i'm on a stride
i'm not just hitting my stride but i'm
on a stride with making content
and so i appreciate you all for always
watching and uh for
new people who are discovering my
content now hello and welcome
appreciate you for being here if y'all
weren't watching this wouldn't be
possible so
i just feel very thankful that i get to
do this and i'm having a lot of fun with
it
oh also like another thing that i
recently started too
as a result of being able to work for
myself is um an ios developer academy
and so my friend and i co-founded it we
just like finished our first cohort and
we're gearing up for the next one and
that's been super fun
especially because it's just like i get
to teach what i know as an ios developer
and it's very fulfilling it's very cool
it's very
challenging taking what i know from here
and putting it
out onto like an actual easily
digestible format
so if you'd like to check it out link is
in the description box down below i'll
also make like a future video like
more fully about ios development or more
fully about the boot camp or something
um it's more like an academy not as much
like a boot camp but
that's been going on in my life and it's
been super fun let's switch from
notebooks for a little bit and talk
about these
little like organizer things that uh
my uncle sent me i don't know about you
but i feel like
asia does organize your pouches so well
um he said that you can use these for
like really anything
like these are really nice because they
actually like if you use a little clasp
on the side they can sit up like this on
your desk
ingenious this one is also like a really
nice medium sized one
so this one i'm actually probably gonna
use is like toiletries or makeup or
something
but you can also use it for really
whatever you want you can never have too
many
organizer patches um this one's called
the hakohako which is also really cute
because that means box box
and it has a little carrying thing but i
feel like as i get older
organizers become so important because
you just accumulate a lot of stuff
and next thing you know you're like well
now i have too much stuff but i don't
want to get rid of any of this stuff oh
hi ellie
hi there how you doing
are you trying to see what's going on
did you just bust through my door
just become so important because you
just accumulate a lot of
stuff and you did you just bust through
my door
anyway what was i saying oh i was saying
as i become an adult
i feel like organ is organizing things
become increasingly more important
because you have a lot of stuff but you
don't want to get rid of any of it you
just want easier access to a lot of
things
next oh goodness this is a lot of stuff
tada
these are little binders actually um
that you can like
change the inside of
which i feel like that's a really nice
alternative to notebooks i mean you can
actually just keep using
them i also have the actual filler paper
inside as well that come in different
colors
these are much smaller and more
manageable than the binders that i feel
like i used to use in school
in middle school i used to get the three
inch binders and spend like an entire
day
like making the perfect cover for it
because there were slip covers that you
can put stuff in
so i'd like print pictures of like my
favorite
boy band or my favorite anime or my
favorite musician
actor whatever and just like put it in
the front
and then also make like spaces for like
friends to sign
so that i can like bring it around it's
basically like
like very simple scrap booking
now that i think about it okay now let's
look at some of the
kind of the smaller things because
they're also very
cute first up is washi tape
i think these are actually so gorgeous
washi tape
is uh can be kind of expensive to buy
just as is
um but it's more fun if you have just
lots of different kinds
because one thing that i've actually
been doing is in gift wrapping stuff
i actually just use washi tape instead
of regular tape because it has just like
that much more special of a touch um
that's fun so i'll probably use these
for that as well
this is like a little tape thing so if
you kind of like go across something
then it puts a little layer of tape on
on it
like double stick tape so you can like
put nice things on it oh and then this
triangle eraser
again what the heck it's so cute
why have we been bothering with like
other types of erasers when you can do
this
it's cool because there's so many
different angles on it so you can like
erase things very cleanly and accurately
one of my
favorite things that he sent is this
ruler uh
it looks like a very simple ruler but
the best part about it is that it
extends like this so that it can be even
longer which is great because i used to
have one that was only this size but i
was like
a little too small but this one goes
it's like a freaking transformer one
thing that i've been thinking about a
lot recently is just kind of like
what are the next two years gonna be
like for the world and for me
and for everyone around me i think it's
gonna be really interesting to see how
things turn out
i feel like maybe this is like a 90s 90s
kid thing
but i feel like back in the day in like
the 2000s specifically the early 2000s
life was so peaceful
but it could also be because i was just
so oblivious to everything that was
going on in life
and ever since basically like the 2016
elections i've just been like
wow there's a lot of [ __ ] that's
happening in the world
uh and so yeah i don't know i don't know
if it's just like this is just what
happens when you become an adult
because when you were a kid you didn't
pay attention to things because i'm sure
in the early 2000s there was a lot of
stuff that happened
but it makes me think a lot about like
man
i'm like living through history every
single time anything big
happens i'm like this is history so
anyway i hope you enjoyed this video
hope it wasn't
weird or boring which is always my fear
when i'm making videos
but uh yeah i feel like it's been a
while since i did a stationary haul
video and it's also been a while since i
did like a stream of consciousness video
a lot of things are happening up here
all the time and
i personally enjoy watching stream of
consciousness videos from other
youtubers because it's cool to know
about
what they think and how they think
because people are so different in the
way that they think and perceive the
world is really cool to hear
but it is kind of a jumbled mess in here
all the time so i'm sorry if none of it
made sense but
um yeah hope you enjoyed the video
regardless maybe i'll bring back
favorites videos again
because i do want to talk about things
that i really like
like recently i've been really into my
little my like slippers that i bought on
amazon
and yes they're not the cutest thing but
they're cute
enough and they are so comfy to walk on
and my knees
are very lucky and thankful to be
wearing them stuff like that as well as
like all the stationary stuff
like i want to talk about what i want to
talk about sometimes
and i know that like sometimes in the
comments y'all are disappointed that i'm
like
not talking about like the tech industry
as much anymore i think my channel is
always going to be
like centered around the tech industry
and
kind of like peripherally about it
because that's just like a part of me
and i can't
undo that and i also not rejecting that
part of me either
but i'm not always going to talk about
coding and i'm not always going to talk
about silicon valley because i
am an independent person who has her own
feelings and interests outside of those
things even when i was working in tech
that was true
so i hope you allow me to like play
around
and make different kinds of videos that
i want to make
because it's fun i've got a lot of great
videos coming out in the next few months
a lot of them are going to
really revolve around helping you all
get a software engineering job
i feel like i can really like double
click into that and explore
lots of different topics and provide
advice
and tips for you so that you can land to
the job that you want
and also get through college and kind of
like all the things that happen
in like uh switching to tech and like
finding a new life and all of that and
hopefully i can do that in a
holistic and helpful manner so if
there's any topics that you want to see
as always let me know in the comments
down below i'm also relaunching luco's
corner soon the newsletter is coming
back i've been growing my team to help
me do all of these things so
it's an exciting time and i can't wait
to bring it to all of you all
so make sure to subscribe and i'll see
you next time
bye